la extrema crisis social política
sanitaria y de seguridad de Haití genera
divisiones en la ONU Estados Unidos y
México Proponen dos resoluciones ante el
Consejo de Seguridad una para sancionar
a los responsables de la crisis y otra
con el fin de permitir la intervención
de fuerzas internacionales
la segunda resolución en la que estamos
trabajando autorizaría una misión de
asistencia de seguridad internacional
ajenal ONU para ayudar a mejorar la
situación de seguridad
China y Rusia se mostraron reticentes a
enviar una misión extranjera para el
momento en que un gobierno haitiano
elige enviar una fuerza de acción rápida
Haití esperamos recibir la comprensión y
el apoyo de las partes de Haití o
enfrentará resistencia o incluso
provocará confrontación violenta de la
población en el país miles de ciudadanos
salieron a las calles para rechazar la
posible intervención también para pedir
la renuncia del Primer Ministro Ariel
quien días atrás solicitó ayuda
internacional para controlar la
situación en el país actualmente la
capital Puerto Príncipe y otras zonas
están bajo dominio de bandas criminales
estas dificultan tanto la entrada de
suministros como de ayuda médica en un
momento en el que la nación vive un
rebrote de cólera que ha dejado decenas
de Muertos
hoy Ariel Henry hace un llamado a las
fuerzas internacionales para que pongan
un pie en la tierra de yang de salim
Permítame darles una lista de todas las
veces que Estados Unidos los
imperialistas estadounidenses hicieron
eso
eh Le pedí a Alice a Mary Kate Y es que
en el pasado una misión de la ONU la
minuta causó múltiples conflictos en el
país desde un brote de cólera que mató a
10.000 personas pero también acusaciones
de violaciones a niños y adultos entre
otros escándalos